there's a lot of people that work hard
in this town I think you like really up
there I'm top top 200 well actually yeah
like how much stuff are you actually
working on like Monday morning of next
week because it does it does feel like
you have a million things going on at
all times not I I'm kind of I'm reaching
the the uh ending of a lot this Leo
coming out then I have space man coming
out in a couple of months and then I'm
starting over I have nothing in the in
the bank right now so that's good that's
always a lot of work though when you got
to start over and sit and write and get
together and and jam that's always a lot
of work so I'm curious you've done I I
am a big fan of your work and you've
done so many cool things what do you
think was the most nervous you've been
for a project before stepping on set
that first day that's a good question
man I can't I can't I'm really not great
at remembering exactly how I felt
uh didn't want to let Nicholson down
sure that was probably nerve-wracking
those few first few days until uh we got
the rhythm going that that that was and
then there's those uh serious movies
that you
say uh I hope I get this right
because I don't want to let down to
everybody who works so hard putting it
together you know that that hits me hard
but I'd say the first day on all of them
you you just
you're nervous until you get the Rhythm
Donald southernland told me that the
secret is to film something and that he
will only film something from the middle
of the movie the first few days because
by then people buy into what I'm doing
oh that's cool and I was like that is
ingenious that's a very good one yeah
yeah couldn't believe it so he was
smoking weed in Animal House day day six
is that the first time you meet Donald
Southerland and anal when he's smoking
weed with the kids I don't remember I
don't know if it was applying back then
a little more fit anyway um so I really
enjoyed Leo and the thing that I really
like is that it has a there's messages
in the movie but you're you're eating a
brownie while you're getting those
messages yes you know what I mean so
talk about that aspect of the film we
didn't want to hit anything too long and
too hard but it's just want wanted to
the premise is going through you know
what elementary school kids think about
what they go through the stress of it
and having that ner the nerves of saying
oh man they think I'm growing up I have
to move to middle school I have to be
ready and um just just wanted to hit hit
the things they think about the ways to
try to conquer fears but not too
heavy-handed just do a hit and run sure
one of the things about animated movies
is they often change a lot uh during the
production you know you could start here
and you're ending up over here so how
did your character how did the film
change through the making of the film
yeah that's that's good you write a
draft you you put it together you do the
animatics you look at it you show it to
people show it to people around the
office then you start showing it to
people who don't know anything about the
movie and you make adjustments to see
what they're clicking with what they're
following what they're lost with that
kind of thing and uh but that's that's
the best thing about working creatively
on an animated movie just as a comedian
you find Opportunities you two years
later into a project you say you know it
might be funny if Leo does this call up
everybody the staff gets together and
you try to implement it and and if it
works great talk a little bit about
working with Robert because I I've been
a fan of Roberts for a long time TV
Funhouse all the SNL what was he like as
a director being you know what I mean
somebody you trust a th% he's a genius
we all love of them uh when I was first
on Saturday Night Live there was a few
guys on the show that you just said well
that's a whole other thing Jim Downey
Smigel Jack Handy uh Conan guys like
that you were just like can't beat them
Odin Kirk uh so having Smigel run run
the show I never felt like we love
jamming and thinking of of stuff
together but uh his instincts are pretty
amazing I also think he's Fearless with
yes that's true and it's just like I
mean I think about what he did going to
the episode one line as Triumph in New
York City like the things he's done is
triumph the comic dog oh my goodness
he's he's you know he is fearless the
puppet helps him a little bit but in
real life he's pretty Fearless too he
he'll He he'll say what needs to be said
you hosted SNL I believe in 2019 yes he
helped me write a bunch of those too and
so I wanted to know what was that like
going back to host again or to host and
uh have you thought about doing it again
yes yes I'm very friendly with Lauren
and we talk about doing it get a lot and
I and I and I love the cast and I I'm
friends with a lot of people in the cast
so uh I would love to do that again just
got to find the right time where it
makes sense almost like when you have a
clear schedule next year it seems like
it's opened up yeah we'll get there no I
I I would love it's a great week and
I'll tell you I remember with
Smigel I think it was late Friday night
when I was hosting the first time back
and he
said you really should do an opera man I
was like oh yeah okay and he goes I said
I don't have one he said yeah all right
let me write it and he just wrote it
he's a mad man the last time I spoke
with you before the strike you were
talking about safy brothers I know
there's a movie so what's a status on
that we're not sure right now we kind of
missed the opportunity of baseball
season because of the strike so we it
was uh a lot of it was going to be shot
during during uh live baseball so I it's
it's it's going to take a minute we're
figuring it all out right now not not
sure when it's going to happen on that
note sir it is always a pleasure to talk
with you I wish you nothing but the best
you're the man buddy good to see you for
real